I'm here with Emily our biology content
fellow to talk about PCR or polymerase
chain reaction which you've actually
done a lot of why have you done PCR PCR
was kind of the mainstay of my graduate
project where I built all sorts of
different recombinant DNA molecules and
use them to learn things about plants
and so what does PCR in particular do
PCR basically makes you a lot of copies
of a particular fragment of DNA that
you're interested in and and why and so
how does that like why would you need to
make a lot of copies of a particular
fragment of DNA so you might want to be
making lots of copies so that you can
clone it into a plasmid and then do some
other experiments with it that's a big
use so when we talked about cloning and
we're talking about sticking a fragment
of DNA inside of a plasmid it's not like
you're just taking one fragment into one
plasmid you're doing that with many so
you needed a lot of fragments of DNA
exactly that is exactly it and you might
start with a very small sample of DNA
and so you just really need to read
where else would you have to do PCR PCR
is used a lot in forensics it's also
used a lot in medical diagnostics so
this could actually be your DNA that was
being checked to to see if you have a
gene that would predispose you to a
particular condition all sorts of really
practical applications because it's hard
to identify just one one fragment of
that gene so you'd want to you want to
make copies or as they say amplify it so
that you can run it in gels and stuff
and see how all of those molecules how
big they are or something like that
exactly if you were just looking in your
DNA pulled out of your cell that would
be a needle in a haystack so this is how
you can really zoom in and look at just
the thing you need to see
okay so you've drawn some diagrams here
and I actually have never done PCR but
you have so I'm going to tell you how I
understand it happening and then you
tell me if this makes sense so what you
drew over here this is this is
double-stranded DNA just you know and
could have been from a sample of
someone's hair or whatever else and
let's say we want to replicate or make
many many copies of a fragment of this
and so let's say the fragment that we
really care about is the fragment
roughly from there to there this part is
what we want to make we want to make
multiple copies of and so this first
step denature ization denaturation
denaturation have trouble pronouncing
this weird word it's a weird word you
have 96 degrees Celsius so this is
almost at the boiling point so it's
quite hot and that that separates the
two strands precisely and so once
they're separated then you can cool
things down although this still isn't
that cool 55 degrees Celsius would be
very uncomfortable but you would cool it
down to this and then these primers show
up and so you know one thing to remind
ourselves is this process is happening
inside of a test tube or in a big
solution so you you heat it up the DNA
the two strands separate and you just
have this primer lying around so the
primer is something that that you've
ordered from a company and you've
ordered a lot of it so you put in a ton
of primer in your reaction so that
there's a really good chance that when
you get to this step here called
annealing that a primer is going to bind
to many of your pieces of DNA so this is
our this is our solution is this all
happening in water water with some some
salts and stuff floating around yeah
okay so we have our solution right over
here you'd put whatever your initial DNA
sample is in there and once again it's a
very small amount you'd put a lot of
that primer so you'd want to put that in
a lot of surplus let me do that in a
blue this magenta color you obviously
wouldn't see it in real life it would
just all dissolve it would just look
like a drop of liquid it would look like
but for visualization but you put a lot
of primer and so you've heated up the
DNA strands separate and then when you
cool it back down this primer is going
to be specific to the ends of the region
that you want to copy exactly and so
when you go to the when you order online
or
ever that you want a certain primer
you're going to pick the sequence of
that primer to be specific to the
regions you want to copy exactly that's
super important okay
and so when you cool it back down the
primer attaches and then you heat it
back up not quite to the 96 degrees
Celsius but to the 72 degrees Celsius
where you extend those and I'm assuming
since we're it's called polymerase chain
reaction that this is where the
polymerase is involved that is exactly
where the polymerase comes in
so the polymerase the polymerase is what
is actually extending this and is it so
I can I'll just draw a polymerase enzyme
right over there doing doing the
extending and is it any type of
polymerase enzyme could I just take like
you know the polymerase for my cells and
throw it in there so you actually need a
special polymerase because you need one
that is going to be pretty heat
resistant so as you were mentioning even
the cool step of this process is not
something that your body would want to
be hanging out in so the the polymerase
is actually from a really heat tolerant
microorganism and and what what is that
it's called a tack polymerase
thermophilus aquaticus I think makes
quite a mouthful and they founded it at
heated vents this organism that is able
to stand these high temperatures but but
that that I guess leads to another
question is why well why do you have to
why do you have to heat it up to begin
with I guess just to separate the two
strands that's really the key reason you
just have to get them apart you don't
have an enzyme to do it the way you
might in a Cell so heat does the trick
okay so I get it so this is one step I'm
guessing I'm getting at least the
polymerase part of the of the PCR where
you heat it up the strands separate then
you have all of this extra primer there
the primer because there's so much
primer the primer is much more likely to
bind to at the at least at this part of
the sequence then for these two strands
to get back together at this point and
then you have the polymerase to tack
polymerase in particular and you would
have added that at the beginning you
know the tack polymerase I'll guess I'll
put it in this I'll do it in a
and a yellow color so you would already
you would also put all that TAC
polymerase in there and what say you
know these things aren't these things
aren't robots they don't know exactly
what they do they just bump into things
in the right way and react in the right
way and you also have to add a bunch of
nucleotides yes absolutely your reaction
is not going to work if you forget the
nucleotides so the attack polymerase
when you heat it back up again after the
primers have been attached is going to
start adding all of these nucleotides
and what do you just wait a certain
amount of times it will just keep going
on forever it'll keep going on for a
while usually you do pick the length of
that step to match how much time you
expect the polymerase to need to
complete your fragment on but it kind of
will stop either it'll fall off or it'll
stop when you go on to the next step
okay so this I get this is so far so so
far we have after one cycle would you've
written here after one cycle we would
have doubled at least that part that
part of the sequence that we care about
although we might even have we might
have copied even beyond that sequence so
what where's the chain reaction coming
to this so I guess you can interpret
chain reaction in two ways and one is
that's sort of what the polymerase does
is it you know adds things to make a
chain but there's actually even more of
a chain reaction to mention here and
that's that we're actually getting this
kind of exponential process going on so
you do it one cycle you get to this
situation right here you heat it up the
Strand separate you cool it down the
primers attached you heat it up again
the tack polymerase does it's does its
job and I call polymerase it goes from
the 5-prime of the three prime direction
we talked about in that very location so
now you have two strands but now since
all of that stuff is in that solution
you can just keep you can heat it up
again now each of these two strands can
turn into or these two these two double
strands can now turn into four single
strands then you can cool it down again
now they get primers attached to them
and there's still the same primer
because we still care about the same
sequence and then that can key and so
now you go from one to two to four and
so you keep repeating this and so how
many times would it be tip
for you to repeat this cycle so like 35
might be a pretty typical number of
cycles to do depends a little what
you're doing but you're going to do it a
lot of time and so if you do this
35 times I mean each time you're
multiplying by 2 so it'll be two to the
thirty fifth power which is well over a
billion times so and how long would that
take you've done this before
um depends on the length of your
fragment but usually like two to three
hours so in two of the hours you can
start with one fragment and get into the
billions if it's perfectly efficient
which I wish it always worked but you
usually get quite a few pieces made and
one thing that I was that I've always
wondered when I when I first learned
about this and I'd like to go to a lab
and do this with you is it is okay I get
that you have your primer than the and
then the the polymerase is just going to
extend it like that but I was like well
it's you know it's going to be how does
it know where to stop and you explained
well on that first pass it might not
know where to stop but then when you
start going in the other direction it's
going to so over here and when it goes
in the other direction it's going to hit
a it's going to hit a it's not going to
have anything else to copy exactly and
so then you're so most of the pull of
the billions of molecules that you
produce are going to be both ends kind
of a nice clean cut the vast vast
majority exactly fascinating